i love that hold on simmer down hot
sauce you got to keep it sleek keep it
sexy you know what i mean yeah i had a
boy
okay johnny mountain you want to get out
of here and like go hang out
go for a drink who's going to get you
out of jail hi i'm
andrew horton and i play brandon sampson
hi i'm melanie kapoors and i play the
mysterious chloe samson in jupiter's
legacy i'm ian quinlan and i play hutch
hi i'm leslie bibb and i play lady
liberty
my name is josh demel i play sheldon
sampson the utopian hi i'm matt lanter
i play george hutchins aka skyfox
i just fell right into those deep blue
eyes there so gorgeous i give that a 10.
we are the cast of jupiter's legacy and
we're here with buzzfeed to take a quiz
to find
out which character we actually are
okay first which random superpower would
you
love to have the power to predict the
future
the power to control the weather i love
that hold on simmer down hot sauce the
power to turn fire into water
the power to learn any language the
power to know when someone is lying
the power to erase the last two minutes
of someone's memory
dude i said this yesterday i want to
learn every language yeah i want to go
everywhere in the world and just be able
to blend in and not
be looking like a tourist the power to
control the weather i'm going to go
storm style
i want to control the weather too
because it would be so nice when it's a
rainy day or so you're feeling down it's
like
bring in the sunshine i'm picking the
weather
no you're not i am seeing the weather
okay johnny mountain
fire in the water i'm gonna do the power
to know if someone's lying i already
have that power
no you don't what is your greatest
strength
i always keep a secret i'm creative i'm
organized
i'm a problem solver i'm adventurous i'm
an
optimist my answer is incredibly boring
i'm organized
organized too many alarms too many lists
i go this crazy i think i'm too
organized to the point where it's
actually detrimental
i think i'm a really good problem solver
guys i'm so many of these things
i can't pick one you're adventurous yeah
you always do crap
you know he's always doing stuff he's on
a boat or he's running around he's
screaming at the air
he's wild about josh jamel i want to
pick a problem solvers but i'm going to
pick
so practically i am going to pick the
not exciting
i'm organized get a great sponsorship
with the container store
by the way my dream pick a color scheme
for your superhero costume
is it pink white and black green blue
and yellow
blue red and black orange pink and
yellow purple white and green or
black white and gray i think i will
choose the pink white and black because
i just love that color scheme and it
gives me chloe vibes and i love it i
think we already know what i'm choosing
you're taking orange pink and yellow
right right if
it was black white and gray i was also
going to go black white and bright you
got to keep it sleek keep it sexy you
know what i mean
blue red and black i'm going to go pink
white and black
yeah i think i'm going to go purple
white and green i knew you were going to
pick that
no you didn't knew it that kind of
skyfox is well it's exactly what
now which jupiter's legacy hero would
you call
if you were in trouble who's going to
get you out of jail josh the utopian
brainwave lady liberty the flare to
paragon or the flare well i don't think
anyone's choosing me let's be honest
um i'm gonna say the flare because i
feel like he's gonna get it done really
quick i'm gonna be like you want to get
out of here and like go hang out
go for a drink yeah go for a drink yeah
let's do that
lady liberty powerful af
man i will choose the flare too because
tanika and i are very bonded
we call ourselves thumb and louise and i
just know she has my back
not brain he would sit there and just
revel i'm going obvious utopian on that
one
yeah i had a boy utopian ripped open
those bars i saw that scene
i know you guys saw that too it'd be
easy for him to bust you out
i'm going with the flare josh i would
get you out of jail i'm going to be a
narcissist i'm gonna call lady liberty
because she's a ride or guy
which city would you love to visit rome
paris
new york city bangkok london
or dubai dubai only because i haven't
been there i've been to all of the other
places
i would love to go to london to visit
andrew obviously
but i think we will see each other again
soon and i'm a huge absolutely don't
waste the journey nerd i'm a huge gregor
roman history nurse i'm gonna go with
rome i'm going with rome too
it is gonna go together road trip it's a
clutch day
yes come along with us i don't wanna be
a third wheel great i was because i was
just being polite
bangkok i've never been to dubai so i
will pick dubai i love
paris so much i'm gonna go back to paris
and finally pick a comic book tv show
or movie to watch the boys
one division watchman the dark knight
avengers end game or wonder woman i
think i'm gonna choose
other dark knights these are some
fantastic choices though they really
really are fun but i am also gonna have
to say the dark knight because it's
in my top three films of all time one
division was
phenomenal but i do love me some heath
ledger
and me some christian bale so i'm
actually gonna have to go with the dark
knight as well
i watched wandavision i loved it i
thought it was creative thought it was
fun and interesting so i picked it i'm
going dark knight
i'm going to pick wonder woman
did you get yourself yeah i got you too
oh i got myself nice i got hutch
oh i'm chloe sampson there you go
see we're more elected to you than those
you're ambitious witty
and logical why thank you like hutch
your intelligence is your greatest asset
you're someone who wants to make this
world a better place and you'll do
anything to achieve this
takes you a little while to open up to
new people once you do they become your
bff for life
your personality matches chloe you're
honest
passionate and outspoken like chloe you
marched the beat of your own drum
and you don't care what others think
like father like daughter
i feel so seen how dare you see me how
dare you see me i feel so naked
thanks buzzfeed for hanging out with us
make sure to tune in to jupiter's legacy
may 7th on netflix
boom oh very good that was nice